Remember when people couldn't stop talking
about Duck Dynasty's Robertson family? A few
short years ago, this close-knit Louisiana
clan was the talk of reality TV, but everything
changed after Phil Robertson's notorious GQ
interview in 2013. The Robertsons managed
to stay on the air following their brush with
controversy, but lost a vast portion of their
audience, and were dropped from A&E in March
of 2017.
"Well, hey! There ain't nothin' I can do about
that now, we done screwed the pooch here!"
Did the Robertsons just disappear after that?
Not by a long shot. So, where are they now?
Phil & Kay Robertson
In an interview with local news station KNOE
8, Phil and Kay Robertson said they don't
have any grand plans for the future. Phil
said he's basically going to spend all day
in the woods, while Kay is looking forward
to getting back to a "quieter life." Phil
wasn't sad to see them pack their cameras
and go.
"I, for one, was thankful it ended. There's
a lot more to doing these TV shows than most
people realize."
While the Robertson family patriarch would
like everyone to think he's happy checking
duck blinds all day, he's actually been pretty
busy outside the Louisiana wilderness. During
the 2016 U.S. Presidential Election, Phil
became politically active, voicing his support
for Republican candidate Ted Cruz before switching
to supporting Donald Trump, and he's been
quietly playing behind the scenes in conservative
politics ever since.
Phil and Kay also travel around doing speaking
engagements, mainly preaching their religious
beliefs in what Phil described as, quote,
"helping our neighbors and living a godly
life." Recently, he's taken to Facebook to
advocate for the NRA, which should surprise
exactly no one.
"My idea of happiness is killing things. Boom
bom bombombombomb bow."
Willie & Korie Robertson
The Duck Commander himself, Willie Robertson,
also took a deep dive into politics as the
show tapered down, speaking at the Republican
National Convention in 2016. Willie attended
the 2017 Presidential inauguration and even
visited the White House. Lately, he's hinted
at possible new TV projects and discussed
an expansion of the family's West Monroe,
Louisiana warehouse.
"I'm fixin' to go crazy redneck up in here!"
But like his dad, Willie's also not resting
on his laurels. He and his wife Korie decided
to reopen Willie's Duck Diner, a local family-themed
restaurant once featured on the show. Along
with his partner in the restaurant, Willie
was also instrumental in organizing relief
efforts for victims of Hurricane Harvey.
Meanwhile, Korie has parlayed her TV fame
into a brand of her own. Already a New York
Times bestselling author, Korie released her
latest book post-Duck Dynasty, called Strong
and Kind: Raising Kids of Character, which
she paired with her Strong + Kind collection
of housewares, jewelry, and accessories.
But there's one area where she and Willie
differ. In a surprising break from the family,
Korie told CNN that she didn't share her husband's
enthusiasm about Donald Trump, and stated
that her and her husband agree to disagree.
She also called on the president to, quote,
"be a leader that unifies, that brings people
together."
Sadie Robertson
Arguably the breakout star of the show, Willie
and Korie's daughter Sadie has become a full-blown
media figure in her own right since the final
duck call, starting in 2014, when she nearly
took home the mirrorball trophy on Dancing
With The Stars. Since then, she's also become
a bestselling author, launched clothing lines,
and started an acting career.
Just like her mother, Sadie's taken the concept
for her book, Live Original, and turned it
into a full-blown brand, which includes a
blog and live show. Sadie views herself as
"a beacon of light in an oft-dark world,"
and she's working on a follow-up book, Live
Fearless, which she says is about her "journey
of finding freedom."
John Luke Robertson
The second oldest child of Willie and Korie,
John Luke also got a jumpstart on his post-Dynasty
career. In 2014, he authored a series of children's
books called Be Your Own Duck Commander before
venturing into non-fiction with Young and
Beardless: The Search for God, Purpose, and
a Meaningful Life, a memoir about camp, volleyball,
and anguish over things like his girlfriend
getting texts from other guys.
Taking a cue from his family, John Luke also
seems to be building a personal brand. He's
launched a blog called Young & Beardless,
as well as promoted the handle through his
social media accounts, although a quick look
at recent posts suggests he may already have
to consider re-branding to Young & Scruffy.
And if that doesn't work out, he clearly has
a future in endorsing canned fish.
"Bumblebee tuna. Bumblebee tuna. Bumblebee
tuna."
Uncle Si Robertson
"I'm like a bat. Kaboom! Kapow! Punch! Zap!
Kick!'
As the last season of Duck Dynasty was airing,
Uncle Si launched his A & E spinoff series
Going Si-ral, which pitted the quirky technophobe
against the world wide web.
"I got myself a show about the internet. I'm
not even sure what that is, yet."
He's also busy working on new music and about
to start touring with his band, Uncle Si & The
Sicotics, which is comprised of himself, his
daughter-in-law Marsha Robertson, and Bridgette
Tatum.
Si must have learned a thing or two from his
solo series, because he and his bandmates
now routinely post lengthy Facebook Live posts
that keep fans engaged, but also play out
like a reality show. And if you just can't
get enough Si, they're also selling ringtones.
"It's ringin', ringin', ringin'! Hey, Jack!
Answer the phone!"
At any rate, it looks like diehard Uncle Si
fans are still able to get their fill of the
eccentric Vietnam vet, and for that we say
God bless the internet, Jack!
"Hey ya! Oh! Woah!"
Jase & Missy Robertson
Though there was already a huge internet kerfuffle
when photos of the pre-beard Robertson clan
surfaced online, it happened all over again
in September 2017 when Jase Robertson lost
a battle with the buzzer for a great cause.
Jase agreed to shave as part of a fundraiser
for Mia Moo, the foundation he and his wife
Missy founded, which is
"...dedicated to raising awareness and funds
towards research, treatments, and causes of
cleft lip & palate."
Jase and Missy were moved to start the foundation
after the outpouring of support they received
when their own daughter, Mia, was born with
the condition. The goal for #ShaveJase was
to raise $100,000 dollars, after which Jase
would shave and cut his hair and record it
live. Though they missed their goal, Jase
honored his pledge, and posted the video to
Facebook via his new venture, CamoFlix, which
Jase described as
"...a place where outdoors people, hunters,
fisherman, fisherwoman can go and share videos."
Think of it like YouTube, only you need a
fishing license or a hunting tag to upload.
A few days after Duck Dynasty's final episode
aired, Missy Robertson told the Daily Journal,
"Right now, we're taking some time off to
rest and re-evaluate what our next steps will
be…"
"I'm enjoying being able to travel to see
[my sons] Reed and Cole, who are currently
living in Nashville and Malibu, and spending
time with Mia and all her activities."
Missy has yet to strike out on a completely
new venture, but she's continued her work
with her jewelry line, Laminin, which focuses
on pieces which are, quote, "made by women
who have come out of very difficult situations."
Laminin has become more than just a jewelry
retailer—it's also an outreach program.
"All women can come together who would like
a job, who need a job, and that can express
their creativity, and just being a part of
each others' lives."
Through the creation of the Laminin House,
Missy hopes to expand across the United States,
and serve as a ministry to disadvantaged women.
Reed Robertson
Still in Nashville and plugging away at his
fledgling country music career, Reed Robertson
recently released his new EP, although he's
still pretty far from the big time. He told
The Outdoor Experience,
"We didn't have a plan, and we didn't really
have a defined sound that we were going for.
We just got in the studio and had fun and
just wrote, and it just kind of happened,
which is really cool."
Reed was married to Brighton Thompson in October
2016, and the newlyweds have been posting
happily-ever-after Instagram shots ever since.
Jep and Jessica Robertson
Knowing a good thing when they saw it, A & E
greenlit a spinoff for Jep Robertson and his
wife Jessica before Duck Dynasty ended. But
like every other Robertson, Jep and Jess couldn't
possibly have just one iron in the fire, which
is why in addition to operating Jess's jewelry
line, Cavalry, the couple also launched a
podcast, The Jep & Jess Show, in March 2017.
The busy couple said the show would be even
more revealing than before, and would definitely
feature regular visits from the rest of the
Robertson family. So in case you were worried,
yes, all the charm of the reality show is
still intact.
"By the time I'm through, y'all are gonna
pee in your pants, and then you're gonna throw
up."
Yep, charming.
Thanks for watching! Click the Looper icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel. Plus
check out all this cool stuff we know you'll
love, too!